thank you for me it's great to be here
on services this theory is extremely
important University their 6,000
carnival mi mayor enough so we have to
love it san francisco alumni chapter in
southern belle
six trustees almost
insert it's become big report for a long
time limits and wall type items will get
into the topic which attract not here
the future of our education but campuses
of this my last trip the San Francisco
one is pretty melody give you a quick
update on so we can the University
during black tiles president it's doing
very well we feel very good about the
universities I you mark doesn't listen
it which is exactly the right time to do
annual reviews what I say do it well
this is America appreciate every
dimension with regard to stoop interest
in Amanda carding mill and we're just
now going through the end of admissions
process Commissioner order to be set
back tomorrow we got 20,000 applications
1400 spaces in the pressure
which is an all time I every year
presidency is going up and up tell me a
big it's an extruder cap and it's very
reforming interest in learning about
standing our research activities are
hitting on all cylinders and sponsored
researchers also at all time I four
hundred million dollars a year many new
research thrust served during our time
University the biggest change these
games licenses or double faculty triple
funding and other great things the
newest major thrust is in bed early in
march ask all the Scott Institute for
energy innovation
made possible by a very large gift by
choice these her husband shirts also
loved us this is a very important new
thruster University which in every
research university the country's energy
and execute the energy Japanese
according to volunteer is a particular
tape
problems or we can make special
combinations I'm talking about our
external a slit our ability to perform
your decision of Technology just need in
many other positions of course to be
your science information technology just
moving ahead I can't do that another
area is global credit balance of coming
out now leave in 15 degrees of the
reason 14 countries protein and 15 7 and
if you read and done that to 10 years in
Silicon Valley campus which
interventions were very well as our
campuses cut our Australia major
programs portugal singapore new ones and
watching this year in china and you best
folks
one just going extremely pleased about
this great thing from the University now
and even more so in the future an area
which has been a priority for University
during our time as this and second I
will be well and here you see tremendous
things the graphic change our technology
transfer policy several years ago thanks
it works leadership creating a policy
which makes it much easier and faster
for faculty step companies we went from
spinning out to the up companies
here to now 15 to 20 a year we are
second in the country in terms of timber
companies created for dollar sponsor
fees this has been great form intricity
it's been grateful Pittsburgh another
thing you did was to build a building on
the edge of campus back to campus in 10
years you've gotta come back from the
family's genius this building was built
specifically to attract establish
technology it's been extremely
successful in open its doors six years
ago with a flick until and who who will
got too big
move out and they now have 200 people
with engineering center and East third
now but I go round the world it say to
Colonel Kellogg I've got go back it's
going a long time Google is an East
Limpy they guess we didn't want to see
global bout delighted to have them that
big really feel too bad because Disney
didn't happen to her space major misty
resources now this has been terrific
thing university city related to this is
not only better changing tech transfer
policy but it's strong emphasis on
innovation and entrepreneurship from an
educational point of you practice point
of view we've gotten major gifts in this
area this is something as we move on
campus so that should add your z
pittsburgh has been very close and
strong partners in collaboration from
the two universes food disturbing our
capital campaign
instead extremely successfully raised to
date 1 million 180 million dollars those
billions of law passed the campaign will
end on my presidency cause I'm june
thirtieth so it's not too late Renato
can add to that total the money of
course is invariable and very nice time
the success of in there it's also been
about alumni engagement that was a
explicit goal of this campaign greatly
increase our aging and that has been a
tremendous success the turnout tonight
has tested it to that we've tripled the
number of low match Alex a rather than
international their challenges with 222
forces it's just been terrific and not
just a number of checks but the degree
of
appreciative as a great thing for
University this campaign is all
something about building what we call
advancement advancement use that working
forward to alumni relations fundraising
and barley and have today an
infrastructure group of people like
handing it as many colleagues here
tonight the circles that we've ever had
I think across some history that's a
permanently wasn't just and something
that's extremely future tadesse
conferences finally we have a great new
president until I force this exceeded by
subra Suresh
dr. Suresh it's from medium to high
achiever to us to kind of speech ta Tata
we're already used
integrity to take them back position
entails silence became the deep MIT and
then directly National Science
Foundation tomorrow's his last days
next three months working clothes on us
as we affect a smooth transition very
very probably guy just his appointment
was at least of the university's
reputation a lot of planning is inserted
very good they were able to attract some
soup as callable
so that let me turn to the topic a
question though we get to Q&A you can
ask the future of higher education
market I mark and I exactly and that's
why we've got short hop it was an Inside
Higher Education let me sort of set the
stage for this and then pretty good each
other over tomorrow conceit really is
the S&Ls nationally what works for
especially
technology education this is a unusual
moment of our higher education study the
one hand there's a broad appreciation
that higher education is worth more than
ever if you want to get a good job you
gotta have a college degree or some
extent addition there's a particular
appreciation for searching for business
support that we pause to make sure the
law of the same page about the
difference is researching the preceding
the rest of our education so research
university love is as the participation
of Education dedicated equally to the
creation hours of research as it is
separation teaching there are only about
200-250 research universities in America
there are about 4,500 institutions of
higher education that's or 50 or so of
such universities and within that
they're about 60 which dominate the rest
incredibly well enjoy the best way to
certify that is by membership
organization called the a8 you this is a
collection top 60 or so to versity
they're half of basic research this
country knows just as six teams so it
includes just of what you expect stare
like six of UC campuses and communities
in Pennsylvania Perry develop it penn
state of em except so it's bad
connection there's a realization that
those universities certain persons are
especially important for the future
let's go we are a major recent economic
success of this country and will reclaim
the national security inspector over the
last 6 16 years and modestly spoken we
are the future of the country there's an
appreciation that search universities do
because of innovation because of the
people at the trailer who are the
innovators we are the future that's
developer she asian for that in this
country too long but every country in
the world is trying to create a system
of research universities based on and we
know that because always getting called
in some countries that's when I
countries
so on the one hand the upside we are as
important as never happen ever is great
demands on the other view causes and I
reviewed as inefficient places that may
seem opposed to and the fat happy cost
of hiring there's a feeling that quality
of education in institutions of higher
education generally that's specifically
is inferior and we're producing people
who are about really what industry
America leads there is a sense that a
little bit of this there is sort of a
backing off the public commitment to
higher education we see this for the
reduction of state appropriations to
their flagship there's no better example
that
which is many many years of constant
from using system recently
firstly we sit at some a tous wherever
you've ever wanted to cut appropriations
to the state vs I didn't percept
squishes fifty percent over here in dirt
that feeling that tumors that's huge he
person and this is a national now
spawned by the budget problems that
every States based fuel sort of belief
that somehow our universities don't
deserve that high stakes at least this
is just was added all the high cost and
experience has helped
biggest problem is the increases in
tuition of universities why are your
choices got up so much as a state's
offense bughouse it's really created a
very difficult situation both with your
sinister campus they're finally in terms
of disruptive issues I read we have
technology in our language is sleeping
in these discussions in higher and to be
rapidly about the various ways and
that's what hosted there's a sense that
traditional universities that Wallace
or kind of like Detroit automakers
eventually replace it unable change
we're going to be put out of business
people who get I got
maybe but
I don't know what's at extreme talk
through them before what all that
education is really sweet so let me turn
now to really say I talked a little bit
about her
against and if vigorous issue online
technology involvement books may not
remember what it stands for its massive
open online course and books and pioneer
and state and now being distributed
Sarah
fabulous looks rather than successful
asking
and soon forget
numerous serve really captured the
imagination oh that I have to say a lot
of yours who are desperate to be
something in online education so the
authority over sarah said please take
our horses and make news kearney melon
is known as the you can call the
universe university when I think
ourselves as the most interesting I will
try to explain and the reason why we are
ruthless who the person posting is
because even get a suit this being
technology in education the five decals
we've been working on this ever since
silent in the learning as a copy process
and is something worthy of our research
focuses we're with us all the way back
to the systems and it's evolved and
currently Melanie's to restore them take
a rustic
universities have produced the best
theft or available to technology and
education between the bagra for us it's
a serious editing is that about the
moves which is kind of stuff that is
taking the videos of the professor a lot
of our thousand students to sign report
that's a great thing it's a worker if
they might access but that's a sure
about Claudia education experience or
instance but we have done that our
motivation and tireless work that
disturbing this assembly or about being
on why it's about how can technology the
primitive improved learning experience
for students this gave rise to the
libraries or lender got something called
the science of learning center this
Walker watching the woods first Masters
of learning science program well he
thought you could be after wonder where
he would have gone
can implement online education to
education we're going to beat those
first in size it led to the creation of
something called capital tutors they're
distributing now 15 and now or use the
word episode and school systems k
through 12 school system has led to
something that we call oh my that's our
college level cognitive tutor that's
nothing to justice which create a very
rich interactive computer based error
for full semester water courses I'll
leave you with one thing for eternity
but none of these online education is a
contestant and grievously basically
asked the question is to be learning in
turn except for one arts and they stood
up very well in an independent test
third party to do students learn using
are alive as well as students in
traditional that's it that's seen in our
own research on a statistic schools
offer
our own students that is well better
than the students in the traditional but
they've negated in half time as well as
better happened so that's exactly kept
payment hard what everybody's worried
about I wish Tim cost Center but as well
here's the care mostest four months
their persistence that you know there is
a license the team the information
better distance stuff real it's an
engine something proud that I simply
sort of touched on the surface marcin
answered all your questions about the
future of higher education let me say
again everything that's happened in
carnegie mellon that's good during my
presidency mark has even led his
fingerprints on this he's been a
tremendous focus and i can't they
two
you guys here
this way I'd fight start to get too soft
oh you wanna okay there's somebody who
controls the volume wave or something
too okay so not walking in got a chance
to talk to just one or two people I was
to a running late and first thing they
says that no idea what a Provost is and
I haven't really explained it in much
detail but I will tell you and this is
true Provost is comes from a German word
means jail keeper for a long time
there's actually a character in one of
the Shakespeare play that's the the
Provost is literally the keeper of the
keys to the jail so so what I want to do
is pick up on the things that jerry has
introduced and I want to talk at least
initially about it from not necessarily
the perspective right away carnegie
mellon i want to step back there's a lot
of different kinds of institutions
higher education institutions in the
United States how many
4500 we remember us very said of this
very select group of 60 research
universities gonna make comments that
pertain to this group of 60 but it
really pertain to higher education
America that kind of zone now what we're
doing what we hope to be doing it is the
case that higher education in the United
States is at up is between a rock and a
hard place in a very challenging time
maybe you're more challenging than any
time since World War two there's a one
fundamental aspect it's it's poss costs
keep going up costs keep going up
tuition keeps going up as tuition keeps
going up financially does not keep up
although we're seeing you working very
hard to make sure there are financially
keeps up generally speaking too many
students end up getting too much in
depth too much it have carried to any
desk and the situation is really not
sustainable why did the costs keep going
up it's not mainly because Provost's
throughout all these institutions are
terrible the controlling costs are
terrible managers there's something much
more systematic going on sometimes it's
called a strange name is called bowels
disease named after someone inbound all
at what it basically reflexes we have
not improved inefficiency the way we
teach and educate people in hundreds and
hundreds
hundreds of years we do it largely the
same way we always have done is the
teacher saves there's their students who
listen and take notes on what the
teacher says and that's how it's done at
the same time almost every other part of
our economy has had tremendous
productivity increases you can now
produce so much more steel computing
power or wheat with an hour of effort
but we don't have any improvement in the
number of students that we educate
effectively and you do that for too long
a period of time your costs keep going
up relative to all the rest of the
things in the economy that are getting
produced much more efficiently that in a
nutshell is bowel disease it's something
that is going to continue to pervade
higher education until it changes and it
cannot stay the way it is the cost
structure just cannot keep going up
forever now there are other things that
are going on and it's very mentioned
there are there's a lot of lack of
confidence that the taxpayer and the
nature's and the governor's have in what
the particularly state institution
public institutions are doing that's a
factor as well it is a note for those
institutions but the dilemma that is
being faced by higher education is one
that is it's not a matter of who's
president it's not matter if losing
Congress and something that is not
sustainable on his current course what's
going to happen nope nobody knows but
this Jerry mention we believe strongly
that the role of Technology in changing
the way the education is going to
proceed is going to be a tremendous part
of what's happening so the question is
what is the role of carnegie mellon
where's Carly not fit in this we believe
that Carnegie Mellon is extraordinarily
uniquely situated to lead the
transformation that's going to happen in
higher education in the US and globally
just to some degree by that I don't need
lead it in terms of what's going to
happen on Carnegie Mellon's campus or
campuses yes we want to do that and
we'll do that as well but I mean
something broader in leading the country
leading higher education broadly in the
way it's going to have to respond over
the next decade can we talk a little bit
about what I'm speaking of in terms of
and Jerry mentioned we have been
involved in our own very unusual way and
trying to understand education for 50
years plus the two individuals mentioned
herb Simon and Alan knew who were that
they were psychologists who study the
brain is studying the learning so one of
the great strengths Carnegie Mellon has
had his cognitive psychology how people
think how people learn not I'll just
supposed to learn not guessing whether
they learn from a lecture but actually
trying to study how people learn and one
of the things that comes out of that
very long history of research in that
area is the importance of active
learning the importance of learning by
doing the importance of student
engagement and all of those things may
strike you as aha that's odd because the
way we normally teach lock is lectures
lectures are in a lot of ways the
antithesis of what we found out over the
years makes it best for learning
lectures are very passive lectures are
somebody else talking and students
passively taking notes and then being
tested on the degree to which they
somehow internally figure out and pat
passed an exam so that's part one about
seeing you brings to the table the other
thing that no and Simon both were were
they were the inventors of the field of
computer science they were the inventors
in particular of the field of artificial
intelligence and such an odd combination
kind of psychology on the one hand
artificial intelligence on the other
those have been the two pillars the
Carnegie Mellon has used to approach
this whole area of learning and now
there are other areas one convention as
well something called machine learning
something called serious gaming
something called entertainment
technology now it's not only cognitive
psychology but neuro neurobiology all of
these are the areas that Carnegie Mellon
has established a a strong group of
researchers is any place there is and
being researchers who work together
we're the only place that has
departments in which artificial
intelligence machine learning specialist
combined with cognitive psychologists
this is the origin of the specifics and
Jerry mention of where we have
distinguish ourselves this is where
these things called cognitive computers
came from this is how you embed
artificial intelligence in a computer
that interacts in a very customized way
with students if the computer is
infinitely patient the computer also can
keep track of that particular student
actually more effectively than the human
teacher
can and the computer can be very
attentive to the specifics of how that
student is doing the way that student is
learning what if they're learning way
that student is not learning what
they're not learning and in a nutshell
more complicated a nutshell that's the
heart of the direction the we have taken
which has absolutely nothing to say that
the MOOCs at Jerry mentioned which is
taking advantage of recording lectures
and making them available through the
web and through other mechanisms doesn't
have things to be set for but our
approach has been quite a bit different
not anti note that other approach just
we feel a lot better than another
approach the approach of abasing what
you're doing on transmitting lectures in
the 1950s you could go watch well the
television and you are watching online
learning as there was a program that
taught you how to paint the sunset or
whatever and that's such a
tori analysis to say it's an old old
technology it's coming out in new ways
new things just our approach is slightly
different this approach is very mention
we call the science of learning put an
emphasis on science and we might extend
it to say science and engineering of
learning we're a great engineering
institution we're great at figure out
how to build cognitive tutors how to
build open learning initiative courses
and we're very pragmatic and hands-on so
it's not only the science there's also
the reality of the engineering that in a
nutshell is our approach okay so what is
it that we see ourselves doing and that
framework as we as we look at the want
to focus on two different domains ones I
want to focus on Carnegie Mellon and our
campus the first thing we want to do is
to make sure that on our campus or on
our campuses we provide the very best
way to make this a rich learning
environment for students to make sure
that the best way to teach students the
most effectively most efficacious lee
even the quickness is what we're going
to specialize in as we do that there's
going to be the possibility of taking
professors and moving them out of being
the lecturers and having that be the
modal way the classes work some classes
won't work that way what we intended
hope will be the case is that the
faculty who are we're teaching those
courses
they're not having to do as much of that
they're still overseeing the integrity
of the curriculum what will they be
doing they will be doing freshman
seminars they will be doing senior
capstone experiences they will be
mentoring students in their research
labs they'll be advising students there
are so many things that teachers faculty
are still going to be needed for but
it's going to be liberating to have them
be able to do those things and have the
students will be able to take advantage
of approaches when which technology even
provides better approach to learning now
this is not for all subjects i am not
saying every subject lends itself to
this approach that there are many
subjects for which the approach that
we've been talking about is is it is a
marvelous way to go that's one of three
things we hope to do with receiving
second if we've been doing online
learning dr. online learning we've been
doing online learning for awful long
time we're doing more and more not so
much the undergraduate level where the
personal community experience of the
students is so critical but in the
professional master's level and I think
we do that more and more effectively
than any place I know and we're going to
continue to do more of it the way to
reach out the different countries and
different audiences we
would not have an opportunity and
thirdly this Jerry mentioned we have
established a global network of campuses
and programs global including what we do
here in Silicon Valley local insurance
what we do in other countries that is
unmatched and we aspire to be a
university that is a connected global
network and we're fast on our way be
happy if we talk more pressing questions
kind of flesh that out let me talk about
other things we hopefully see you those
we hope that we can take advantage of
these talents and directions and have an
effect not the Carnegie Mellon that have
them affect the 4450 higher education
institutions that are not like us
they're not worse than us they're not I
mean they're just different than us than
nature the students is different the
nature of what they're trying to achieve
but their desire to have effective
teaching with less resources remains
there in a sense it's our business how
to educate how to understand how
students learn this is an attempt to
move into the business of our business
that by going into the business of what
we do we can apply those approaches to
what's happening in these other
institutions and hopefully have more
impact to help them and to help
ourselves even financially for that end
we will set up a very unique structure
it consists of establishing companies
these companies are not spin out we do a
lot of spin up
they're very proud of but these are
spins these are subsidiaries of Carnegie
Mellon we own them they're our companies
and our companies are going into the
business of trying to change the world
in the ways that we can I want to
mention is what a few of them are one of
them very mention is an enterprise or
Carnegie learning the deals with K
through 12 deals with math it's in ten
percent of all US public school
districts it's really quite an amazing
thing several hundred thousand students
at any given time we have a video
capture transmission of a company called
Panopto we now have 550 institutions of
higher education that have signed up for
Panopto 380 of them or in the united
states it's the fastest growing video
capture company out in that space we
have another company pretty old actually
call I Carnegie that does teacher
training curriculum development is
active in many many parts of the world
and it's now starting to have a very big
impact on its own we have a company
called a qatar which is a an online
learning platform that other
institutions can use and are beginning
to use we have a company called Claire
model which teaches software engineering
certification and give certifications to
most of the leading software producing
companies rough whoa there's 500
multinational companies that
our clients I'm not going to go into all
of these in detail although I'm very
enthusiastic welcome all I just want to
say it's a very unique structure that
we've created these things we hope to go
out into the world have a big impact and
being the vehicle that we change the
world and maybe help ourselves so in
short we've established ourselves in a
very unique way that I think is going to
impact higher education tremendously at
the very time that higher education is
going to be going through the biggest
changes that it's gone through in
decades and decades and perhaps even
four or five hundred years we want to
make sure that it leaves us in our
Pittsburgh campus and our other campuses
providing the best education that we can
and we want to get into the business of
our business to see if we can change the
world even outside Carnegie Mellon
itself so that in a nutshell is kind of
high work we're pointed and I'll talk
and that's the future for attention
thank you very much
and imagine or any questions over there
dr. Fred so there's a rec room yeah so
back to about moles do these why doesn't
handles a lot of opportunity let's to
pretend education just half the cost of
our new University so I take that 20 and
the best improve things by a factor too
pretty quickly I back where it was so
who's lost a lot of questions emily and
i'll buzz computers in a program such up
so the answer i will give is these
things scale forever that is to say if
if you find a method by which you have
taken seventh or eighth graders and more
effectively teaching them algebra for
example or pre-algebra you're going to
be able to continue to add more and more
students with we're going to get you hit
them Oh with regard to Carnegie Mellon
your point is very well taken that that
is to say of trust we aren't going to
plan
thing to double or even increase at all
the size of our undergraduates that this
becomes said simply a method that we can
take advantage of the technology that we
can divert the students from the death
date they provide those students I'll
turn into the faculty we're going to
focus on things about tuition you need I
did feel that too and why is it this
isn't my sins nearly let's imagine a big
education to conquer classes perfectly
efficient we still have the rest on
camera
research and that's triggered by
salaries and other things
so we'll get a temporary stoppage
but we're done that lesson find away the
other equally that we prove that that's
the lab so i would have to answer one is
50% a bad but it's ever well give us a
head start and we started on this one of
the other that Webbie really clothing
what except that suppose that with the
adoption of these technologies of
retirement the result was that you can
produce a three year bachelor's degree
without sacrificing mentioning benefits
from residential residential experience
to the river that we are there probably
this results in the larger student but
i'd recommend is that that the costs in
its to that be a perv I think
oh you going to start off with a hard
question rule is no good you know what a
lot of running running first edition and
and to intuition then nearly every inner
quality adversity acha linearly G+
running yes Alex go what percentage of
the how the self-sufficient is our
research report what imagine it's very
self-sufficient because we've got a lot
of sponsored research right we're in two
lines of business we made mainly
research and education we lose money in
each the more we do more we lose it is
very bad this as well that's why your
donations and gifts attention it's not
the case your honor how much money we
get to do research it doesn't cover the
pasta research and actually the truth
that it's also the case on the education
from so pollution as high as it is
doesn't cover the whole constellation
research grants to cover the half of the
total cost on your research from you
have people think
okay so i have so i can't imagine
although myself in take online classes
in high school um simply because they
ran out of options and he wanted to go
on certain areas so how do you see this
I can imagine as a parent not being very
driven to send my childhood way to
school for the experience I don't see it
as just a learning experience so how do
you think the kids the current the
students at Carnegie Mellon period I'm
really curious about the future
purchasers the the people who are going
to create the demand have you spoken to
them and what do you think it is dumb
besides what's going to make them above
what look how do they feel about it what
do they think about it I'm curious I
have no idea so so my view may not be
shared by Robin as it just just my view
but i think that there's so many
different kinds of institutions in
higher end and CMU is very fortunate to
be in a set that is driven by getting a
very good education or absolutely but
they're also driven by the prestige by
the selectivity by the fact that they
got into the number
one apartment in computer science ER and
drama or other things and that they get
a lot of their value from Carnegie
Mellon through the experience of being
not so much specifics of a given class
goodbye a network of friends and network
of associates we're going to be their
network for their for their lives and
stuff and part of me the quality in that
regard
but of course we all care greater love
student and I'm just curious
yeah but let me I do got her first of
all there's a new us that we need and
introduce its that online or not in fact
we have found our own use of these
technologies that be the best next is a
simple type where students are getting a
lot of content from the technology based
education angry father also experiencing
education in Alaska and with those
working together it's a very powerful
combination because the professor is
tracking how to do it with the online
whatever which by the way is also
gauging technology gives us for the
first time real-time information custom
or not so that's a return student and
student so that already sort of hybrid
approach I think is one is very
attractive schnapps and I think we'll
see more so there's the notion of flip
request that's the first with the idea
that faculty members stop lecture
instead they say go do larger a online
I'm going to trap up quest do show up
here
next week and we'll talk about the
prompt or we'll take what you learn in
going further and apply I think that
sort of thing is very dragging MIT is
very much fun in estero online
tournaments called an ass there are
persistent and their president I think
articulated quite an interesting vision
for how they see themselves using their
own material what he said was a typical
MIT undergraduate is strongly motivated
by project I'm making as I it's true CDs
and Ed firmer this is a is very small
slice of students where the most capable
and they are quite able to master great
deal of material online without any help
from united
17 18 19
support is extremely humid so they are
talking about football experiences the
core the interactive activity becomes
project which motivates the students to
learn they're still getting a lot of
action I've seen quite irrational chill
they're doing something they're
interested foot so they're tracking
their receipts use of this TEDx material
it turns out a peak power usage
community young prince's to go further
using institute sounds just so i think
that i think if we do this work that
I've got them that it could be a really
in ritual facts but so
Jim Jefferies emphasis on hybrid is that
correct in fact loops online throughout
the terms we likely like technology
enhanced hybrid courses tech
all the way back when I went to Carnegie
Tech the big thing was the Carnegie plan
of Education and if you learn the
Carnegie plan there's no reason to ever
have a change the purpose to think there
was learning the fundamentals you can
derive your answers it's different than
the case method that hard reviews and
they were proud somehow or other that
got dropped by the wayside and I don't
think ensure that you another well that
they've got a contract mr. of your mind
no it's that Trump on the way said it
all we can I never hear the news of the
birth Carnegie played out again the
phrases in Houston cocktails absolutely
there I don't think you appreciate how
ok can I found I think but let me let me
answer your point is this very important
I don't think you appreciate how
transformative the Carnegie play it was
that just for hurting attempt but for
all i got everybody in here too that
they were using enticement never until
though don't learn the case method learn
the fundamental and can i say what i
think the English instructor i had was
George Benden he said three things when
you communicate keep simple clear and
concise he says those say you converse
with three men USS saving top with your
secretary
that stuck in my mind there's leaders
too much big words and stuff and not
enough of the net my brother also went
to Carnegie Tech it and he thought his
way what did I learn in Carnegie Tech
problem solved so I think there's still
so fundamental that can exist and I
don't you going to invent a lot of new
things yeah so again it's that moment is
pressing this is very important because
the values of carting develop core
values that what we're all about today
are no different than the core values in
Carnegie Tech or doing they've been
updated to the 21st century as you can
okay but if you ask any alumnus in this
group what was the organizing principle
which you learn I mentioned 99% once a
prophecy and it has not changed at all
they would so if you're the notion at
least your university is that straight
of those poor ideas HP absolutely read
your Pepsi right we're proud from still
in the same fundamental
so the vice president of engineering for
Apple was smallville start up the win
for the high heaven he just said we
employ Carnegie Mellon students because
of their problem-solving abilities so
you should be proud of that that the
carbon plan is alive and well at your
yours it's still very much what we do
always a pleasure to hear me talk being
a very recent treasure it to see if here
I've had the privilege of working with
oli and classroom setting I'm very
curious to hear and touch upon a little
about the integration of a lot of those
technologies within the classroom to
serve something that what the
professor's already teaching in
particular I hosting like it can you
talk a little bit about the data that
technologies like oh I can capture some
kind of curious the feedback loop is for
the student ISM how you know the
feedback that normally the rest are some
kids about student to the students can
be supplemented by what
riding you man sir what was your
experience listen I think it was certain
early stages so I would say that they
were both pros and cons to all I just
from the fat guy and the way it was
integrating in the classroom which
course in a statics and mechanical
engineering course and the way that
Professor Snape that used it was to
introduce the concepts of whatever the
topic we were you at week and come up
with questions into the classroom or
even at fresco I think that there were
booked pros and cons to that approach is
better than reading just the standard
textbook that can be safe about for
short because Ohio Valley two
opportunities to really be able to serve
interfaced with the concepts on what I
think oh I might not be a successful is
the idea of really I guess you touched
upon it like we're addressing people
get out students pain points and so how
even if it captures that thing that what
can we do for the student to be able to
address those pain points so you know if
there was a question answer Q&A session
in the classroom you know is that really
being able to provide the right
opportunity for that student to be able
to learn that concept fully so part of
your question was how is the day that
feedback loops us I'll say three things
what one of them is hopefully the
professor benefits and the students
benefit by seeing what they're
struggling with so the professor walks
in and knows in advance a lot more about
which specific pain points are there
number two all is just being silly
develop and one of the things that the
full cognitive tutors do is they met
enough artificial intelligence and to be
responsive to the student so it really
can get in more fine grade level and
then three hopefully one sees after the
class the whole class is done and afters
have done many different settings to
Mike many different students let's say
calm this is working as well and that we
continuous quality improvement on the
whole courses a bowl it's a good
question it's a fast
question how to take advantage of that
continuous data feedback all right to
Russia what is for an on-camera
for so the first ones taking a fouette
whatever saying in response to permanent
on two balls law appreciated I imagine
this really the core of this issue do
you notice a degree non take up of the
experimental delivery systems from the
international campuses as opposed to the
North American campuses the experiments
with dip military systems within a
second the second question is partly
related to that Ron to what degree do
you feel that US immigration policy
presents a threat to us our chances so
in terms of different camps of taking up
the new methodology week we hope so in
there we like to think that each campus
is a greenfield and has opened up new
ways that the Silicon Valley campus if
really pioneered an extensive learning
by doing in fact everything was
project-based and you learn your
concepts that you want that wouldn't
work this product as it was the one
thing
we're setting our way so I think there's
generally and we try to have there be an
opportunity for pedagogical innovation
that was not fortified as your chances
us emigration pollinating some respects
is terrible it's out of gender threat
the curtain imelda but is a huge threat
to hear you Mike if we really believe
that innovation is the key to our future
it makes no sense whatsoever to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars in many
years to word a forward student PhD and
say thank you very much go home which is
exactly what we do the demand for
Carnegie value education from overseas
is just exploded and we could fill every
one of our classes in every field at
every level many times over from
students from take the company any good
just by the way one a little faculty
our demand is five years ago we have 400
students each other throughout there's
it all of us now Pakistan 414 fibers in
that's a little more than the national
trend National Council area so getting
fabrics white students from all of the
world as you know under our racial
policy these are bosses they can stay
over two years or so and it Bella death
and h-1b visa they go and it's the US
loss in terms of our own ability get
seems different Jim to garba leadership
I think the university to take a lot of
credit but if they're very selective who
they hit possibly the reason they're
successful as they have a very special
group of people to go through it's been
that's really make them look good with
but they're in the position where they
can do that but sometimes they take the
credit for what's going on and basically
smart people will do well no matter
where they are the first the first job I
had successful companies
president he went to college forgiven he
didn't go to college forget so that's
kind of that's a lot was successful so I
think a sense that probably reached the
end here see people nodding off the
other watches thank you for being here I
be remiss though I can introduce to you
dr. Candace chills put your iphone down
for a minute just stand up stand up
spendin see you this is is a leader of
our co liner and you didn't come up to
talk with my phone and then adapt my
truck should scream is hurting abella is
cheap revealed in recent years we are
fortunate to have gotten to where we are
but the front of a Bella we're never
satisfied we have long way to go that we
have gotten where we are is because in
large part due to the support we receive
and I think I think person many
Crystal's over my 16 years and I'll
thank you that they answered support
you're pointing super suresh leg very
well for your continued engagement
reviews thank you very much